as joe biden prepares for his
inauguration democrats push radical
policies and revenge
and we ask whether a worse authoritarian
threat is around the corner i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a vpn
yet visit expressvpn.com
we'll get to all of the news this is in
fact president trump's last day in
office it is the day before joe biden's
inauguration as president
of the united states well you may be
thinking about your finances right now
you might be thinking yourself wait a
second are we going to continue to blow
out the debt are we going to continue to
devalue the american dollar
are we going to raise taxes are we going
to get involved in all sorts of bad
regulatory policy making that sinks the
us economy well if you're worried about
any of those things
you should be looking to diversify your
asset base and this is one of the
reasons you should be checking out my
friends over at birch gold group birch
gold group they'll help you diversify a
portion of your savings an ira or
eligible 401k into an ira backed by gold
and silver they're the premier precious
metals ira company in the united states
with an a-plus
better business bureau rating countless
five-star reviews thousands of satisfied
customers
there's a tidal wave of inflation it is
coming we don't know when
so this is why you should be diversified
you should at least hedge your bets
gold is that hedge text ben 247 47 47
for your free information kit on
precious metals ira or to speak with a
birch gold
representative today time is running out
but you can protect your savings right
now text ben 247
47 47 if you really trust the government
to ensure that your asset base
remains viable it's probably a mistake
at the very very least you should take a
little bit
of your money and put it into gold talk
to my friends over at birch gold group
text ben 247 47 47 to get started so
as we say tomorrow is the inauguration
of joe biden
as the 46th the president of the united
states the inauguration is going to be
kind of a weird ceremony because
obviously the washington mall is
completely blocked off
they've put out some 200 000 flags on
the national mall
they're supposed to represent people who
would gather from the inauguration
they've also put up
56 pillars of light that are supposed to
represent america's
states and territories and um
you know it's going to be an odd site
some of this is because of the pandemic
so joe biden had already announced it
was going to be a very restrictive crowd
even if there had not been safety
concerns about the inauguration there
are safety concerns about the
inauguration so there's heavy military
presence
in washington dc there's barbed wire
that is blocking people off
from places like the capitol building as
well as the white house
we know that joe biden's inauguration is
going to return the cavalcade of stars
we can see that one coming
so the cavalcade of stars for jobiden's
inauguration they are back because of
course hollywood is fully
in the tank for joe biden as they always
have been this is supposed to include
some of the people that we have come to
know and expect
people like lady gaga and jennifer lopez
and bruce springsteen they will all be
back
and and the era of good feelings of
obama will return which means the media
is just not going to ask any tough
questions of joe biden
for the next four years so they've
earned their vacation don't you think i
mean
they really just spent the last four
years being as vicious and brutal to
trump as possible
and honestly asking tough questions of
politicians by the president i don't
have a problem with that my problem is
it's extraordinary selected it's
extraordinarily selective when it was
barack obama
the entire job of the media was to walk
around holding holding a drool cup for
him
when it's joe biden they will go around
wiping his ass but when it comes to
donald trump obviously
they're definitely on top of things well
now they've earned their vacation
they're going to go back to vacation as
soon as humanly possible
meanwhile president trump is planning a
last spate of pardons and commutations
today
he's expected to issue up to 100 of them
that is not expected to include
any members of his family it's not
expected to include himself
in fact there's a fairly solid legal
case that one of the big problems with
with pardoning himself is
it would actually cause the possibility
of prosecution afterward
because then theoretically he could be
prosecuted for some form
of corruption it's not clear who exactly
trump is planning on pardoning uh trump
is going to be
leaving the capital he is not going to
be attending the inauguration the trumps
will be the first president and first
lady to skip
the inauguration in more than 150 years
which is in fact bad luck they should
attend the inauguration the election was
not stolen
it would be a good thing for them to
attend the inauguration but he's not
going to do that
trump is not going to get a big military
send-off he wanted these big military
honors
instead he will have sort of a
scaled-back send off at 8 a.m on
wednesday and then he will head on over
to mar-a-lago mar-a-lago in florida
meanwhile the pentagon has authorized
more than 25 000 national guard troops
to secure the inauguration the fbi
is currently vetting all national guard
members which is
a weird move i guess the idea here is
that they're gonna be members of the
national guard for sympathetic to trump
and may attempt to do some form of
violence there's not a lot of
information to suggest that that is in
fact the case
in fact even the democrats who are who
are making this claim
acknowledge that this is not in fact the
case that there is not a great deal of
evidence to suggest that there's a
threat emanating from within the
national guard
or within the police forces you can
really chalk it up to
a sort of systemic distrust of the
police on the left side of the aisle
a democratic congress congressman named
steve cohen
he's been suggesting for a long time
that the national guard is going to be
risky he went on cnn yesterday and
suggested
that he fears the national guard
the guard is 90 some odd percent
i believe male uh
only about 20 of white males voted for
bible
you got to figure that in the guard
which is predominantly more conservative
and i see that on my social media we
know it
they're probably not more than 25 of the
people that are there protecting us who
voted for biden the other 75
are in the class that would be uh the
the large class of folks
who might want to uh uh do something
they're part of the large group of
people who might want to do something
that's kind of an extraordinary
accusation so again
this is all part and parcel of the
broader agenda for the democratic party
which is to suggest that every single
person who voted for trump or who did
not support joe biden
is a member of the capital riot brigade
they are criminal
uh if they are not criminal themselves
and they support the criminals
the fact that they're now vetting i
understand why they're doing it they're
doing it because obviously they don't
want anything to go wrong or somebody
gets blamed
but the basic notion that the national
guard is rife with people who are going
to do violence
on behalf of donald trump on the day of
the inauguration
not a lot of evidence to suggest that's
true even steve cohen acknowledges
there's not a lot of evidence to suggest
that is true but as i as i mentioned
that the great message going into
the unity the u the time of unity
renewed unity is of course that half the
country is evil
right half the country supported trump
half the country believes that the
democratic agenda is wrong
half the country does not agree with
what is coming next
well that means that they're bad and the
capital riots are just an excuse
to highlight that fact and what we
really need what we really need is
divide the count to divide the country
further so bill maher got shellacked
over the weekend because bill maher
did a monologue in which he he pointed
out that there are about 5 000 rioters
total
maybe i mean in terms of the number who
actually broke into the capital is
probably far smaller
their 74 million americans don't confuse
the two and this is coming from bill
maher
a guy who is wildly non-trumpy a person
who despises
trump i mean bill maher has suggested on
his show that he wanted the economy to
tank before the election just so trump
wouldn't be re-elected that's how much
he dislikes donald trump but mar happens
to be correct about this that when you
conflate
5 000 riders with 74 million americans
there might be something else at work
here
let's not confuse 5 000 people with 74
million
excuse me yes even even supporting the
insurrection
in spirit is well deplorable
but there's a difference between holding
illiberal beliefs and acting
violently on them at least that's what
they always told me about islamic
terrorism
i've preached and still do that you can
hate trump
but not all the people who like him and
as counter-intuitive as it may seem you
can like something run by
without being one yourself okay and he
happens to be right
about every word of that this meant that
bill maher was now on the poop list
for people on the left they were very
angry at bill maher for pointing out
this little fact because the preferred
vision of the left
is that they themselves are the arbiters
of virtue and therefore they get to shut
down everybody who is not on their side
of the aisle far more typical of the
left than bill maher's reaction which is
what a true liberal would say right bill
maher
happens to be much more of the sort of
old school liberal than he happens to be
of the hard left and the distinction
that i've made on the show routinely
literally every day i make the
distinction between the left
and liberals i've made it every day for
the past several weeks when i talk about
this particular issue
is that liberals will say things like we
hate what happened at the capitol riots
we don't agree with people on the right
about nearly anything but they have the
right to say what they want to say
and this has been a thing that bill
maher has said many many times
and good for bill maher on that but the
hardcore left doesn't want that the
hardcore left would like
to push forward the propaganda the 74
million americans are awful
and terrible and therefore need to be
silenced so don winslow
who is a sort of action thriller author
i've recommended some of his books on
the program i like don winslow's
work i mean they're very much to the
left but his writing is interesting well
his twitter persona is far less
interesting so he put out a video
it was called trump's army it currently
has 2.5 million views this video on
twitter
and the entire premise of the video is
that when trump leaves office he's then
going to weaponize and militarize a
giant army of his supporters
in order to do violence and do harm to
others and you
need to be drafted into the counter army
because the battle is going to happen
online
so you need to be the person who
monitors your neighbor you need to be
reporting on your neighbor you need to
make sure that your neighbor has good
views
and here's a little bit of this video
that has gone viral on the left on
january 20th donald trump will become
the commander-in-chief of a different
army
this army
the greatest threat facing america today
comes from within
radical extreme conservatives also known
as domestic terrorists i'm proposing we
form a citizen army
our weapons will be computers and cell
phones we who are monitoring extremists
on the internet and reporting their
findings to authorities
and unfortunately don winslow's view is
not rare on the left in fact
it has infused even people who used to
be quote unquote right wing
and so you've got max boot right max
boot is uh well known as a sort of
neoconservative voice
very interventionist during the iraq war
and then he shifted to the left
as donald trump rose to the nomination
and now he writes pieces like this for
the washington post
trump couldn't have incited sedition
without the help of fox news so he is
now calling for the full onsee
platforming
of fox news i'll get to that in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
now
terrible time to go to an auto parts
store in fact pretty much always
store instead you should just go
directly online because if you go to an
auto parts store
you're probably going to go there you're
going to have somebody recommend you
apart
they're going to order it online they're
going to up charge you for the privilege
of them ordering you the part or you
could just you know skip the middle man
and go directly to rockauto.com they
always offer the lowest prices possible
rather than changing prices based on
what the market will bear like airlines
do why would you spend up to twice as
much
for the same exact parts rocklautter.com
it's a family business serving auto
parts customers online for 20 years
head on over to rockauto.com shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
would you spend
up to twice as much for the same parts
the rockauto.com catalog is unique it's
remarkably easy to navigate you can
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle
choose the brands specifications and
prices you prefer we've got amazing
selection
reliably low prices all the parts your
car will ever need rockauto.com
head on over to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck right shapiro in there how did
you hear about usbox so they know that
we sent you this rockauto.com
check them out right now make sure that
you write shapiro and they're how did
you hear about usbox so they know
that we sent you okay so max boot again
a guy who used to write for commentary
magazine in the wall street journal now
he is writing pieces for the washington
post
openly declaring that the government
should essentially ban fox news
which is about as authoritarian a
thought as has been expressed in recent
memory
he writes in the washington post it's
hard to overstate the enormity of what
happened on january 6
2021 a date that will live in infamy
alongside december 7th 1941 and
september 11 2011 and 2001. this was the
first time the us capital had been
ransacked since the war of 1812 the
first time ever that the united states
has not experienced a peaceful
transfer of power okay i mean to be fair
we're still experiencing peaceful
transfer power
it is it's a peaceful transfer of power
donald trump will leave joe biden will
take place
the army was not used this was not a
coup there was no official mechanism
by which donald trump stayed in office
that is in fact a peaceful transfer of
power the fact that there was mob
violence
does not mean that it is not technically
a peaceful that doesn't that's not to
downplay the evil of the capital riot
it is to point out that that's still a
peaceful transfer of power in which the
military is not used to ensconce a quote
unquote dictator
in office and the fact is for all of the
talk about how the system broke down the
system
didn't break down see that's the thing
the system actually withstood the
pressure that trump was putting on it
it even withstood the pressure that the
rioters were putting on it a republican
vice president
trump's vice president right he stood up
to trump
and said no i am not going to violate my
constitutional duty
the congress of the united states did
not violate its constitutional duty
the senate of the united states did not
violate its constitutional duty
state legislatures did not violate their
constitutional duty secretaries of state
across the land
most of them republican in these
battleground states did not violate
their constitutional duties governors
did not violate their constitutional
duties so i'm just wondering what is the
evidence
that the system broke down because this
is the the great
this is the great lie at the moment
which is that trump was such a threat to
the system that the system itself was at
risk
no the system was never at risk okay
donald trump did very very bad things
over the past couple months the writers
did something fully evil in invading the
capital
was the system itself quote unquote at
risk was there really any chance that
joe biden was not going to be
inaugurated on january 25th no what no
one serious believes that joe biden was
not going to be inaugurated on january
20th the minute the electoral college
voted in december it was over
i said it at the time i said it since i
said the night of the election i didn't
see evidence that the election had been
fraudulent
or stolen i didn't believe it when trump
had said that he had won right okay all
of that
happens to be the reality but the line
from the media is that january 6th
represented a serious attempt to foment
insurrection
in such a way that it would have been an
actual coup okay
that's unrea it is morrikin to a
terrorist attack than it is like
anything else and when you
invade the capitol building and then you
go looking for blood that looks more
like a terrorist attack than an actual
coup but that does not mean that it's
not a peaceful transfer of power
peaceful transfer power is happening
trump is leaving biden is taking office
all of that is happening tomorrow
and the military is not intervening in
any case max boot continues along these
lines because
in order to push for what he's about to
push for you have to claim that the
united states is on the brink of
collapsing from within
right he says the sedition is assembled
at the president's invitation
the wall street journal reports that one
social media post from the proud boys
told their members potus wants you in dc
on january 6
21 impeaching and convicting trump is
the least we can do given his role in
inciting the violence insurrection
but and here's where we go right here's
where it goes next while holding trump
to account
is necessary it is also insufficient
there is a whole infrastructure of
incitement that will remain intact even
after trump
leaves office just as we do with foreign
terrorist groups so with domestic
terrorists we need to shut down the
influencers who radicalize people and
set them on the path
toward violence and sedition and even if
you were to make the case
that there are people who are
encouraging violence or inciting
violence you then have to distinguish
between those people
and people who are just sort of
mainstream conservatives who are willing
to let the legal process
play out or even people who were saying
things that weren't true
about election stealing that is not the
same thing as suggesting
that violence is the necessity but max
boot is encouraging now a full crackdown
right this violative of the first
amendment in the extreme
he says some argue that trying to
silence the voices of insurrection is a
hopeless task the hate will always find
a way to get through
and it's true that there is a danger
that seditious plots will now move to
encrypted messaging apps like telegram
where they will be harder to track
but research from signal labs found that
online misinformation about election
fraud
fell 73 after trump and key allies were
suspended from social media well you
would imagine that if trump was kicked
off social media he couldn't make those
claims anymore
does that mean that it is justified to
shut down the mechanisms of free speech
even for people who are not telling the
truth
but says max boot that even that's not
enough he says that's a good start
anyone who cherishes our democracy
should be grateful to the management of
facebook twitter and other social media
sites
for their newfound sense of social
responsibility we should expect at least
the same level of responsibility
from broadcast media and in particular
from fox news which has the largest
reach
on the right to its credit fox news
acknowledged that joe biden won but
reports
media matters he's now quoting media
matters a partisan left-wing group whose
sole goal in life
is to get everybody on the right
platform get their advertisers canceled
and destroy their lives right that's all
media matters exists to do it was a
david brock project created in
combination with john podesta who was
hillary clinton's deputy
it was designed as a weapons center for
the democratic party
so now you got max boot former
conservative neoconservative
ripping into using media matters in
order to attack fox news i mean
i guess when you go you go all the way
he quotes him saying in the in the two
weeks
after fox news called the election for
biden fox news cast doubts on the
results of the election at least
74 times fox news host mark levin told
viewers if you don't fight january 6th
on the floor of the senate and the house
and that is the joint meeting of
congress on these electors then we are
done
the pro-trump insurrectionists we're
listening now so it's mark levin's fault
now
so mark levin suggested that people use
means inside the senate and the house
in order to challenge electoral votes i
disagreed with mark i talked openly on
the show about how i disagree with mark
with whom i'm friends and who i have a
great deal of respect for
okay that does not change the fact that
mark did not call for violence
but max boot wants mark levin shut down
he wants fox news shut down
he says cumulus media one of america's
largest talk radio companies has ordered
its hosts to include some fox news
personalities to stop spreading false
claims
of election fraud if only cumulus were
doing a better job of enforcing its new
policy but fox news itself has no such
edict
james and catherine murdock part of the
family that controls fox news just
called on media property owners to stop
propagating lies that have unleashed
insidious
and uncontrollable forces if james
brothers james brother
lachlan and father rupert won't listen
large cable companies such as comcast
and charter which carry fox news and
provide much of its revenue in the form
of user fees
need to step in and kick fox news off
well we should expect better behavior
for media executives we shouldn't count
on it cnn
notes that the uk doesn't have its own
version of fox news because it has a
government regulator that meets out
heavy fines to broadcasters that violate
minimal standards of impartiality and
accuracy
the united states hasn't had that since
the fcc stopped enforcing the fairness
doctrine in the 1980s
as president biden needs to reinvigorate
the fcc or domestic terrorism
may be only the beginning rather than
than the end of the plot against america
so in other words it is time for the
government to forcibly step in
and use the fcc to crack down on views
that max boot does not like
that needs to happen right
authoritarianism is the only protection
against supposed authoritarianism
right that is the idea here the threat
of authoritarianism on the right is so
grave
we were so close to the end of the
republic on january 6 that now you have
to step in
in order to protect democracy you have
to shut down the mechanisms of
individual rights
okay that is the point that max boot and
others on the left are making
and they're going to voluntarily undergo
a form of social ostracism to ensure
that people cannot work
and people like deborah messing the
actress who came out and said that she
would not appear
on any platform any network that
platforms mac and any well big freaking
deal
wow what a threat she says if i ever see
kelly mcinandy on a panel on a new show
or hired by a network i'm immediately
ceasing to support every single
advertiser
on that network retweet if you agree
de-platform hate
and this is the goal go after the
advertisers go after sources of revenue
try and destroy any outlet that does a
thing you don't like
and the folks who are doing this
proclaim that they are advocates for
freedom because after all they are
protecting freedom
in order to get to this logic you have
to assume that the threat to freedom was
so widespread and so grave
on january 6th that it necessitates the
shutdowns of basic first amendment
freedoms
and this is the argument that's been
made in germany it's called stripe bear
democracy the basic idea is that
the mechanisms of free speech allowed
the nazis to rise
never mind that hitler actually was
barred from publication for a while
after he was in jail for the beer hall
pooch didn't really help very much
okay the bottom line is at the nazi
party in germany has been banned for a
long time nazi symbols have been banned
for a long time the sale of mineconf has
been banned for a long time by the way
has that stopped the
rising of the neo-nazis in germany not
particularly much
but it doesn't matter the idea is that
you can ban those views because those
views are anti-democracy and so if you
stop those views
from being propagated you protect
democracy okay maybe that's a fair
argument when it comes to the nazis
i tend to think that it's not
particularly helpful me being the
orthodox jew not a fan of nazis as it
turns out
i still think that that may be bad
policy by the germans that the best way
to reject nazism is to take it head on
and explain why it is wrong
okay but even if you were to use that
logic with regard to nazis
to label 74 million americans who voted
for trump
in that category to suggest that fox
news is in that category that in order
to protect democracy we have to shut
down the first amendment
that is authoritarianism so in a second
we're going to get to
authoritarianism and where the threat of
authoritarianism lies in the united
states because
there's some authoritarianism on both
sides but i think on one side it has
some institutional control it does not
have on the other side we'll get some
more of this
in just one second first let us talk
about the fact
that we learned in 2020 the internet can
be a godsend for a variety of things
okay well one thing that you should have
been using the internet for before and
now you definitely should
is for your stamps right there is no
reason why you should go to the post
office instead
you should head on over to stamps.com
stamps.com allows businesses to do all
of their mailing and shipping directly
from their computer
no need to leave their home office or
home office stamps.com has saved small
businesses all over the country
thousands of hours
tons of money now you can too with
stamps.com you get the services of the
post office and ups directly on your
computer plus
big discounts on mailing and shipping
rates here at daily wire we've saved
tons of money tons of time we've been
using stamps.com
since stamps.com brings the services of
the us postal service and ups directly
to your computer wherever you are
stamps.com is a must-have for any
business whether you're a small office
sending out invoices or an online seller
shipping out orders or even a giant
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
with stamps.com you get five cents off
every first
class stamp up to 40 off priority mail
up to 62 percent off
ups shipping rates stamps.com it's a
no-brainer make 20 21 the year you stop
wasting time at the post office go to
stamps.com instead no risk with my promo
code shapiro
you get a special offer it includes a
four week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale
no long-term commitments or contracts
just head on over to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage type in shapiro that is
stamps.com
promo code shapirostamps.com and never
go to the post office
again okay so the sort of authoritarian
mindset
of the left is being extended to
virtually every area of american life
the attack on the social media companies
from the left
has been how dare those social media
companies value free speech
now on this show i've been very critical
of the social media companies for their
arbitrary and opaque standards
when it comes to censorship they do not
make clear why they are banning certain
people they do not make clear
the the consistent rationale because
there is no consistent rationale they
are reactionary in the extreme
the left's response to this is well
there shouldn't be reactionary they
should just ban everybody i don't like
so mika brzezinski is now blaming mark
zuckerberg saying that zuckerberg
destroyed the country
she's saying this from her perch at
msnbc less than
five years after spending oodles of time
with donald
trump hanging out with him and mocking
other presidential candidates here's
mika brzezinski blaming social media
and its free speech values for
everything bad that is going on in the
united states
cheryl sandberg mark zuckerberg you guys
are pathetic you have you make
no you you make absolutely no reason
about your actions you could have done
this a long time ago
you decided to do it now huh i wonder
who's going to be president now
maybe this will make him happy no you've
just shown him why you need to be shut
down
you need to be shut down nobody
needs what you have to offer you have
destroyed this country
and quite frankly it's still happening
right now okay so again the idea here
from everybody on the left universally
not people not liberals people on the
hard left is that the big thing to blame
here is freedom of speech itself
the right is to not like the political
right rights are to blame for the misuse
of rights
and so we have to shut down rights and
we have to make sure that the only
informational dissemination
takes place via us it takes place via
monopoly
on the left okay so there is a
description of this sort of behavior
the description is authoritarianism okay
so for a long time
there's been this idea that is prevalent
on the political left that the only
authoritarians are on the right this
springs
we're going to do a little bit of a
history and political philosophy lesson
here
this springs from a book from 1950 from
a guy named theodor adorno so adorno was
a frankfurt school theorist frankfort
school theorists were people who
came over just pre-war they came from
weimar germany
uh they saw the nazis rising and they
came over to the united states they were
largely marxist in orientation
theodor ardona was really interesting
sort of social critic and music
critic very talented musician actually
and he ended up at uh at university of
berkeley
along with a bunch of other members of
the frankfurt school and in 1950
he put out a book called the
authoritarian personality now the book
is deeply flawed
right it is it is based on faulty social
science research
but it makes the basic argument that
there are people
who are sort of proto-fascists and then
america churns out these proto-fascists
right that america creates a mindset
that makes it ripe for fascism why
because america it turns out was too
conservative
for adorno it turns out that the only
way that you could really
not be a fascist was to be on the left
was to be a marxist
he created something called the
so-called f scale f meaning pre-fascist
personality
the authors of that study this 1950
flawed study they suggested quote
the modification of the potentially
fastest fascist structure
cannot be achieved by psychological
means alone the task is comparable to
that of eliminating neurosis or
delinquency or nationalism from the
world these are the products of the
total organization of society and are to
be changed only as that society is
changed
right so the basic idea is you have to
remake all of american society so it
stops churning out
these proto-fascists now the way that
these fascists were identified was with
this
scale the so-called f scale which gave
you a bunch of questions and if you
answered too many of the questions in a
quote unquote authoritarian way
this meant that you had a a
proto-fascist personality or a potential
fascist personality
and the left took this up with alacrity
because essentially what it did was
medicalize
anybody who's conservative the basic
idea was that if you're on the right you
were an authoritarian
okay but in fact it turns out that
there's a grain of truth to the idea
that people do have authoritarian
personalities now the left twisted for
for generations the left suggested that
only the right had authoritarian
personalities
right-wing authoritarianism does in fact
exist so there's a harvard social
scientist named robert altemeyer he
created a right-wing authority
authoritarianism scale right what
characterized you as being a right-wing
authoritarian
and he detected three character traits
that he said made somebody a potential
right-wing
authoritarian here are the three
character traits that exist on the right
can you see these and some of the
capital rioters right these sort of
authoritarianism here
one is authoritarian submission
willingness to submit to established and
legitimate authorities at least in their
own minds
right so for a lot of the people who
believe that donald trump was telling
them the truth
that donald trump could never be wrong
and that donald trump was the only
legitimate authority in the united
states you see that sort of
authoritarian
worshipful submission to trump in we're
going to run into the capitol building
and try to overthrow the auspices of
democracy
right the second factor is authoritarian
aggression aggressiveness approved by
the authorities
against a particular outgroup right so
again if you're rushing into the capitol
building and you are attacking police
officers and you're trying to attack
congress people because you believe that
your leader whether or not this is
justified you believe that your leader
has ordered you to do so
that is in fact an indicator of
authoritarian aggression according to
the right-wing authoritarianism scale
developed by harvard social scientist
robert altmeier
the third characteristic is
conventionalism which is defined by
adherence to approved social conventions
and so the basic idea there is that if
you believe in sort of traditional
values then this makes you a right-wing
authoritarian if combined with
authoritarian submission and
authoritarian
aggression okay so altmeier and other
folks on the left found that there's
nobody on the left who's authoritarian
well it turns out that was rather
self-flattering because like adorno
altameyer is of the left
and so he created an incredibly faulty
scale to try and measure left-wing
authoritarianism
okay so left-wing authoritarianism it
turns out does in fact exist
there's a university of montana social
psychologist his name is lucian conway
he took altmeyer's exact scale that was
used to measure right-wing
authoritarianism
and then he just substituted some words
right he
instead of for example saying that i
submit to proper
governmental and religious authorities
rather than listening to
the rabble right which was used as sort
of a right-wing authoritarian mindset
he just said instead of religious and
religious authorities it's scientific
authorities
right now when you take that statement
you flip it to the left obviously a huge
swath of the left
believes that you have to listen to the
governmental and scientific authorities
you cannot listen to anybody who
descends from those authorities right
that sounds very much like much of the
left today so lucian conway simply took
altmeyer scale
and then he flipped some of the premises
and it turns out not only does left-wing
authoritarianism exist it exists in huge
numbers
right conway found that the highest
score for authoritarianism was for
liberals
on left-wing authoritarianism he says
our data suggests that average americans
on the political left
are just as likely to be dogmatic
authoritarians as those on the political
right and those left-wing authoritarians
can be just as prejudiced dogmatic and
extremist
as right-wing authoritarians it turns
out that the content
of the dogma is just different so
there's some sociologists who came with
character traits for left-wing
authoritarianisms remember
the right-wing authoritarianism
character traits are authoritarian
submission right you submit to a great
leader
authoritarian aggression you do
aggression at their behest and
conventionalism
meaning that you adhere to approved
social conventions
well as you could predict the left-wing
authoritarianism
scale right the character traits that
you're looking for are revolutionary
aggression
designed to quote forcefully overthrow
the established hierarchy and punish
those in power
top-down censorship directed at wielding
group authority as a means of regulating
characteristically right-wing beliefs
and behaviors and anti-conventionalism
reflecting a moral absolutism concerning
progressive values and concomitant
dismissal of conservatives as inherently
immoral
an intolerant desire for coercively
imposing left-wing beliefs and values on
others
and a need for social and ideological
homogeneity in one's environment
hey does that sound familiar any of that
do you see that in american life
you see the revolutionary aggression
green lit
by leaders in the left wing in the
democratic party
do you see top-down censorship and a
desire for top-down censorship
on the left do you see
anti-conventionalism
a moral absolutism that says that
progressivism is true
conservatism is inherently immoral and
we need to coercively impose our
left-wing beliefs and values on others
and we have to purge right do you see
that on the left
today and which is more prevalent the
sort of right-wing authoritarianism
that you see on the right culminating in
the capital riots or the left-wing
authoritarianism you see on the left
which one is in the halls of power which
one has taken over our university system
which one has taken over our media which
one has taken over our social media so
theodor ordono who originally came up
with the with the idea of the
authoritarian personality and first
wrote it up in that very flawed 1950
book
later in life he was teaching at the
free university of berlin
1968 and there was a group called sds it
was a german
social democratic kind of revolutionary
group
and in europe much the same sort of
stuff was happening in the late 1960s
that was happening in the united states
you had students who are violent
aggressive taking over universities and
adorno
who had escaped europe in order to avoid
the holocaust
right he wrote to a fellow frankfurt
school theorist named
marcus okay and adorno mentioned
that a bunch of these revolutionary
students had broken into his offices
they had then occupied his offices and
treated him horribly and he had to call
the police so he wrote to herabra
marquise again another
marxist frankfurt school theorist he
said we had to call the police who then
arrested all those they found in the
room
they treated the students far more
leniently than the students treated me
or dorno wrote that the students had
displayed something of that thoughtless
violence that once belonged to fascism
the response is what's interesting so
herbert marquise was one of the most
influential thinkers on the left for
most of the 1960s
he was the author the coiner of the of
the slogan
make love not war and he was a proponent
of what he called repressive tolerance
he called it liberating
liberating tolerance so liberating
tolerance was the idea
that you could stop people on the right
from speaking
so as to prevent them from violating
your tenants of tolerance
which sounds very much like left-wing
authoritarianism so marcus wrote back to
adorno and chided him for having called
the cops
he said our cause is better taken up by
the rebellious students than by the
police
and he argued that violence from the
left was merely fresh air
so again mark hughes
other members of the left they were
perfectly willing to acknowledge
right-wing authoritarianism but
left-wing authoritarianism does not
exist
and this is the blind spot for america's
political left they do not see
themselves clearly at all in the mirror
i am perfectly willing to acknowledge
that there is a segment of the right i
think it is fairly small
that is authoritarian in nature that
seeks an idol that follows that idol
that is willing to do aggressive
violence on behalf of that idol
right that does not tolerate dissent i
think it's fairly small i think the
evidence that it's fairly small
is that 74 million americans voted for
trump and like a few hundred morons
decided to invade the capital
and many of those were devotees of
fringe q anon
conspiracy theory that is absurd in its
basis
and ridiculous in all of its
implications on the left
the description that i just gave of
left-wing authoritarianism how rife is
that
in our institutions when i talk about
revolutionary aggression approved by
those in power
when i talk about top-down censorship
sought by those in power when i talk
about anti-conventionalism seeing your
own morality as absolute
everybody else's morality is bad and we
need to coercively impose our beliefs on
everybody else
and we need social and ideological
homogeneity we need to purge everybody
how prevalent is that i think we all
know the answer the answer is that is
incredibly prevalent
if you look at the institutions of our
society the threat of authoritarianism
it exists on both sides but it is
predominant predominant on the left
the threat of authoritarianism is is
fringe and dangerous when it comes to
the right it is mainstream when it comes
to the left
the institutions of our society have
decided to preemptively purge
people who do not agree with them the
pages of the washington post
have been can you imagine anybody on the
right side of the aisle
literally writing editorials for places
like daily wire claiming that we should
de-platform
that we should censor that we should use
the government to shut down cnn or msnbc
i've never seen anything remotely like
that have you i have not i've not seen
that in the wall street journal
i've not seen that at daily wire i've
not seen that at the federal list i've
not seen the washington examiner all
evil right-wing outlets according to the
left
i've never seen it on fox news by the
way and yet this is a commonplace
assertion on the left
but what max boot argues which is that
the fcc should be cracking down and
barring fox news
that is not a fringe idea okay that
appeared in the pages of the washington
post
okay the new york times makes these
sorts of contentions all the time and
then
speaking of ideological homogeneity and
top-down censorship
imposed from above and speaking of
approval for revolutionary aggression
the new york times fires its own op-ed
editor for printing an editorial from
tom cotten a sitting united states
senator
suggesting that rioting and violence
should be met by use
of the insurrection act in order to call
forth troops to quality
right this is this is not a fringe
philosophy on the left left-wing
authoritarianism is
ripe on the left and rife on the left it
is all over the damn place
when we talk about the perversion of our
institutions when we talk about the
threat to the american way of life and
the threat to your rights
when we talk about the social
authoritarianism that eventually is
going to percolate into governmental
authoritarianism
the chief threat of that is not from the
right
i know there are a lot of people on the
left who look at trump and they say
that's a guy who talks like an
authoritarian and a lot of the time he
does
talk like that okay trump's language has
been horrible along these lines he says
things that sound authoritarian all the
time
and then you know what happens the right
doesn't let him do them
i understand that there is a line that
is going around that the entire right
approved donald trump for the last few
months
weirdly again every person in a position
of power to actually do something
did not go along with this okay donald
trump
was never for one moment in serious
possibility of remaining president
on january 20th once the electoral
college certified and
there was very little doubt the
electoral college was going to certify
given that states all over the country
republican and democrat
with state officials who were republican
under pressure from trump directly
ignored him and did their constitutional
duty i have zero
faith that that constitutional duty will
be done by a bunch of people who
inherently believe the constitution is
itself an obstacle to utopia and is evil
right who believe that their
institutions should be militarized
against people on the right
you wonder why people on the right field
is deep and abiding threat it's because
every institution of our society
is now being militarized on behalf of a
philosophy of left-wing authoritarianism
nearly everyone hollywood purges
hollywood bands
your corporation will fire you if you
don't post the proper
square during black lives matter the
government
will force your children to learn things
they ought not learn or threaten to
defund your church
right get rid of its tax exempt status
if you refuse to do what the left wing
wants you to do
so when it comes to everyday life it is
a softer form
it is a nicer form it comes with a smile
it doesn't come with a bunch of people
dressed in in buffalo horns invading the
capitol building
but it comes with a lot more power and a
lot more threat to your daily life
we're going to get some more of this in
just one second first
let's talk about the fact that you can
always upgrade your employee base you
can always
make your employees better and the way
to do that is you head on over to
ziprecruiter.com when you post a job on
zip recruiter gets sent out to over 100
top job sites with one click
then zip recruiter's matching technology
scans thousands of resumes and profiles
to send you the most qualified people
for your job
if you are really interested in a
candidate you can even invite them to
apply for your job with one click
zip recruiter will send them an email
from you you stand out from the
competition we've been using zip
recruiter
right here at the daily wire for years
it's so effective that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate through the site
within
the very first day now businesses have
had to pivot during the pandemic
find better employees there are a lot of
people out of work right now who are
looking for a job a lot of employers who
are looking for people
to hire the best qualified employees
this is why you need ziprecruiter you
can try it for free right now at
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire at ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e
just head on over to ziprecruiter.com
dailywire zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire ziprecruiter.com
dailywire okay we're gonna get some more
of this in just one second what is
coming next because
the left-wing authoritarian threat which
is going to be crammed down
by the government but is present in our
social lives the authoritarian mindset
which is predominant across america
right now
that's going to continue full scale a
unity is only unity under joe biden if
you acquiesce
to that form of philosophical
authoritarianism
first remember last thursday it was a
big day for the daily wire we made our
entrance into entertainment content
with our very first feature film run
hide fight it's awesome it's an awesome
thriller
it has values that you will like it
doesn't slap you in the face
there is a reason that rotten tomatoes
currently has given it like a 22
positive score from the credits and a 98
positive score from audiences
the feedback on it from our folks is
unbelievable if you missed the movie if
you
missed run hide fight head on over to
daily wire you can stream it on demand
from our website mobile or streaming
apps on apple tv and roku if you're not
a member yet use promo code rhf to get
25 percent off
that is rhf for 25
off again there's a reason the critics
hate it and there's a reason that you
love it that's the kind of entertainment
we want to provide
to you the film is not overtly political
it is intense it is for mature audiences
only it starts isabel may who gives a
terrific performance and thomas jane and
ronna mitchell
run height fight it follows zoe hall a
high school student coping with the
recent loss of her mother all she wants
to do is finish out
her last few days of senior year in high
school and then go to college instead
she has to fight her way
through an attempted school massacre so
if you saw the movie and despite the
left thought you actually have something
good to say about it please go and share
it with the world go write a review
online go to rotten tomatoes or post on
your website
it's time that conservative opinions are
heard in the world of entertainment
we're starting to see great reviews
coming out
and again we're excited to continue to
bring you excellent stories hollywood
refuses to tell if we're going to fight
back in the culture war
against cultural authoritarians then we
need your help please head on over to
dailywire.com remember you get 25
off when you use promo code rhf that get
that's 25
off when you use promo code rhf go check
out the movie and become a member we
really appreciate your help
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
because when it comes to left-wing
authoritarians taking over the reigns of
the government and taking over the reins
of the institutions
you can see how this works right all
unity will be quashed unless you agree
with the left-wing authoritarian mindset
right and that means a complete
rethinking of the constitution of the
united states constitutional rights are
bad
because they effectuate the possibility
of dissent winning
well we have to make sure that people
view the constitution in a in a
horrible light we have to make sure the
declaration of independence is viewed in
a horrible light
instead we have to suggest that there's
a hierarchy of victimhood that allows
you to speak
and that if you are not cognizant of
that hierarchy of victimhood then you
must be barred
from public life and this is how you end
up with ellie mistah
who's over on msnbc and now in
washington journal on c-span and he says
the constitution is
in its essence a racist document so any
possibility by the way
of a of a country in which we unify
around founding principles is
absolutely destroyed by people who wish
to take the institutional reigns
and then use them against people they
dislike here is a ellie mystal
suggesting that the constitution
essentially needs to be thrown out
because it's racist
i believe that the constitution is a
racist document i believe that it was
written
in uh it was written at a time when the
people were racist it was written
to support a white supremacist state um
and that's and it's structurally still
that document
i tend to think that the 14th amendment
with its guarantee of equal protection
and substantive due process for all
is enough that if applied to the rest of
the document
to save the constitution from its
original sense
to redeem the constitution from the
racism and bigotry and sexism
of its founding okay it's fun to see how
he takes the 14th amendment and then
just inserts
in there the phrase substantive due
process for those who are not uh
fluent in legalese what he is saying
there essentially is that the supreme
court of the united states is basically
just supposed to overrule anything that
ellie mistel doesn't like that's what
substantive due process means
it's a nonsense phrase that was inserted
by the supreme court in order to achieve
particular
political ends but again this philosophy
which is that the constitution
is basically either a tool or an
obstacle on behalf of left-wing
viewpoints that is now being promoted
openly
by cnn again your objective at name and
news they put out a report today it's
titled trump administration issues a
racist school curriculum report on
martin luther king
jr day okay first of all this is part
and parcel a broader effort by the left
to suggest that republicans can never
quote mlk
right if you say that martin luther
king's dream which was that people be
treated as individuals
rather than as representatives of their
race if you say that that is a very good
thing
and it's a good thing that america
celebrates that ideal the left will say
no no we need ideological homogeneity in
order for you to quote mlk and tony
hostin is representative of this view
on the left if you want to cite mlk
approvingly for that sentiment you also
have to buy into
all left-wing tropes and if you voted
for trump you are simply not allowed
to believe anything that mlk believed
her sonny hostin doing this routine on
abc's the view
i saw today unbelievably unbelievably in
my in my view
ted cruz kaylee mcinerney uh rona
mcdaniel melania trump
quoting dr king tweeting dr king those
were the same people
that were like melania trump with this
birther live ted cruz
with challenging uh you know the
electoral college
uh you know uh kaylee mcinerney just
over and over again with her propaganda
how dare they
how dare they try to quote
dr king on the the celebration of his
birthday when they
enabled enabled a racist president
okay so this is my favorite part is that
mlk day was supposed to be a unifying
moment around which all americans could
could unify and it would be good if all
of your political opponents
cited mlk approvingly but if your
political opponents cite mlk approvingly
and they are political opponents and
you're on the left
that's very bad then you're not allowed
to talk about mlk ever ever ever again
so anyway cnn
has now come out against what is called
the 1776 report
okay so the the president had an
advisory committee they put together the
1776 report which was designed
to be a counter to the 1619 project and
it is a
fulsome explanation of the ideals of the
declaration of independence
it talks about the greatness of the
united states it says things like this
of course
neither america nor any other nation has
perfectly lived up to the universal
truths of equality liberty justice and
government by consent
no nation before america ever dared
state those truths as the formal basis
for its politics
none has strived harder or done more to
achieve them right that is the basis of
the 1776 commission
and they have it's a it's a report well
worth reading with your kids
it talks about the value of the
declaration of independence and the
value of the constitution
of the united states it quotes people
ranging from thomas jefferson
to frederick douglass it talks about
race in the constitution
it quotes ronald reagan of course and
and the basic idea is that there are a
bunch of challenges to american
principles that are now rife
on the left and this of course is
exactly right it talks about the evils
of progressivism
which held that essentially the
declaration of independence was
irrelevant and the evils of fascism
the evils of communism and then it talks
about racism and identity politics and
points out
that the civil rights movement was a
grand and glorious movement culminating
in the 1960s with the passage of three
major legislative reforms affecting
segregation voting and housing rights
it presented itself and was understood
by the american people as consistent
with the principles
of the founding and martin luther king
jr himself said when the architects of
our republic wrote the magnificent words
of the constitution
and the declaration of independence they
were signing a promissory note to which
every american
was to fall air and then says the report
the civil rights movement was almost
immediately turned to programs that ran
counter to the lofty ideals of the
founders
the ideas that drove this change had
been growing in america for decades they
distorted many ideas of areas of policy
in the half century that followed
among the distortions was the
abandonment of non-discrimination and
equal opportunity
in favor of group rights not unlike
those advanced by john c calhoun and his
followers i've written about all of this
i've talked about it on the show
there's nothing racist about this report
cnn's headline is quote
trump administration issues a racist
school curriculum report
on martin luther king jr day so you are
now in direct
opposition to martin luther king jr if
you believe that america was
gloriously founded did not live up to
its ideals and progressively realized
those ideals over time
and that identity politics strips away
those ideals
now you must be banned right you're
ostracized you're a racist
if you believe all of those things
okay we're gonna purge our public
schools of these sorts of ideas
we're going to cram down on american
citizens ideas they do not agree with
we will use our institutional power
outside government in order to do that
we will use the institutions of the
media of hollywood of social media
you'll see it in every area of your
culture you'll see it in your kid's
schooling
right this is what the left-wing
authoritarians would like okay and
then they would like to do it using
government itself and then they would
like to formalize this arrangement they
would like to use the powers of the
executive in order to push
all of this stuff forward they want to
weaponize every element of the
government in order to push forward a
left-wing viewpoint
this is why james clyburn is now openly
saying joe biden you should just use
executive orders
right you know what we i love this all
the institutionalists donald trump's a
threat to the institutions
here's james clyburn openly saying if
congress won't do something joe biden
doesn't
know wants to do joe biden should just
ignore the constitution and do what he
wants to do which
by the way is kind of authoritarian is
it not
and like a governmental level the
takeover of legislative powers by the
executive
is an authoritarian leaning here is
james clyburn
i have said to joe biden that i do feel
that when he lay out his agenda and
fight participation from the other side
if they're going to be recalcitrant if
they're going to throw up roadblocks
go on without them use your executive
authority
if they refuse to cooperate that is what
abraham lincoln did
to stop dismantling slavery that is what
uh harry truman did
to start the integration of the armed
services
all these things were done by executive
order okay i mean that is
some wild stuff there from james clyburn
but remember the real authoritarian
threat is a bunch of
droogs and idiots innovating the capital
and then
not achieving any of their any of their
goals or purposes
okay that was dangerous that was evil
and that was wrong the authoritarian
threat that's gonna come
for you and your rights is not gonna
come from morons dressed up as buffalo
inside the capitol building it's gonna
come from people who are coming with a
smile
and with institutional power in order to
cram down their viewpoint
in the name of their own virtue alrighty
we'll be back here today with an
additional hour of the ben shapiro show
coming up soon the matt walsh show
airing at 1 30 pm eastern be sure to
check it out over at dailywire.com
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavo wiedowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez the show is
edited by adam's psy events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica crams the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021
on the matt well show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show